[Music]
good afternoon everybody and welcome
today's session is all about app
performance my name is Joel Newman and
I'm a product specialist on the Google
Play business development team in that
capacity I worked with Android
developers of all shapes and sizes
helping them to leverage the tools
available in the Google Play console to
build successful app businesses now I'm
gonna kick things off with a quick
reminder of just how important
performance is to app business success
and why Android vitals can be a critical
tool in helping you improve your
performance then my colleague Fergus
product manager for Android vitals will
join me on stage to talk about some of
the ways we're enhancing the platform to
make it easier to understand and action
your performance information then my
colleague Wojtek from our developer
relations team will come on stage for a
technical deep dive to talk through some
of the common causes of performance
issues and how to address them finally
we'll wrap things up by talking about
some of the resources available within
the Play console itself and beyond to
improve your performance and if we have
time we'll try to do a brief Q&A now
first I think it's important to remind
ourselves of why performance is
important and I think this is intuitive
right like we as users nobody wants to
deal with an app that crashes frequently
or freezes or is janky but at Google
Play we have data that drives home just
how important performance is we did an
analysis of all the reviews on the
Google Play Store over the past year and
found that when leaving a one-star
review over 40% of the time users cited
negative performance indicators like
stability and bugs in fact this was the
number one cited issue within
one-star reviews now on the flip side
when leaving five-star reviews over 70%
of users mentioned positive performance
indicators things like speed design and
usability now why is this important well
not only are ratings and reviews a
direct and leading indicator of customer
satisfaction and not only do ratings
you're heavily in the place to our
search algorithm but ratings and reviews
correlates strongly with downstream
business KPIs
things like engagement retention and
monetization a great example of how that
performance can impact key business KPIs
it comes from this study we did an
analysis of all of the games in Google
Play and we compared those with the
lowest crash rate versus those that the
highest crash rate and we found apps
with the lower crash rate saw almost two
and a half minutes more of game play per
day and this was even a bigger trend
when we when we looked at a in ours
which are more frequently looked over
relative to crash rate we found that
users spent almost three minutes more
per day in the more stable apps and this
may not sound like a ton of time but
when you look at this over a yearly
basis this would translate into 18 hours
of additional gameplay per user for
games that are played on a daily basis
now another reason why performance is
incredibly important is that it's
becoming an increasingly important
important signal within Google Play for
both search and discovery as Google Play
is committed to service surfacing only
the highest content to our users we're
increasingly taking into account
performance signals particularly those
related to stability and battery
consumption in both our Play Store
search algorithm as well as our
algorithmically generated
recommendations in in addition to that
performance signals Factor heavenly
heavily into our decisions around our
editorially curated curated content this
includes our featured new and updated
apps collection as well as editor's
choice and coveted Google Play Awards
and Android excellence if you want your
app business to succeed your app needs
to be discovered and technical
performance is an increasing part of
that discovery within the Play Store now
it's exactly because of that increasing
importance of technical performance that
we launched Android vitals last year
android vitals is an initiative by
Google
improve the stability and performance of
Android devices by surfacing to
developers in an easily understandable
and readily accessible way the most
important performance metrics in battery
stability and rendering this comes from
over a hundred million users who have
opted in to share the data with Google
and with you our developer partners and
since the program's launched a year ago
it's been an incredible success we have
over a hundred thousand developers
including some of the biggest names on
the Android platform regularly engaging
with the vitals console
to understand their performance issue
and and create fixes now it's because of
this incredible engagement that we've
seen some really nice gains at an
ecosystem level when we compared reviews
in the Play Store today versus a year
ago before we launched vitals we see a
really nice uptick in those people
leaving five star reviews talking about
things like speed design and usability
but perhaps more importantly when we
look at people leaving one-star reviews
we've seen an almost 20% decrease in the
number of people talking about things
like stability and bugs and battery
consumption and that's only possible
because of the incredible work that you
have done as a developer community to up
the quality of Android apps and for
those of you who are new to the platform
it's really important that you keep pace
with the rest of the developer community
who is helping us move in a positive
performance direction now I think where
these games at an ecosystem level are
interesting you might wonder as an
individual developer yeah but how does
that really matter to me well I want to
showcase a couple of examples of where
individual developers have seen
incredible gains because of android
vitals one of my favorite case studies
is Starbucks now Starbucks is obviously
an incredibly popular app they have over
15 million downloads on the Google Play
Store they started using android vitals
into several in december admittedly
several months after the launch of the
program and when they started using
android vitals they were alerted to a in
are issues that were not even on their
radar and they were able to use the
report
in the console to identify common
underlying causes for the ANR's
that were caused by a third-party
library they removed that third-party
library and saw a 70% reduction in A&R
rate within a week that they saw a
similar and actually even better
experience with crash rate because
Android vitals is a platform level tool
it's able to detect crashes that were
not detected by Starbucks's third-party
crash SDK because these crashes were
happening at app start before third
Starbucks's third party crash sdk had
even an initiated using the vitals
reporting they were able to identify an
underlying cause push a fix and they saw
an 85 percent reduction in crash rate
within a week these are impressive stats
now it's worth calling out that vitals
and it is a common misconception is not
just for apps it's equally relevant for
games a great example comes from Kalu
developers of the super popular subway
surfers app which was actually the first
game to pass the 1 billion install mark
on Google Play when subway start first
started using android vitals they
discovered a sudden increase in a in our
rate use the reports to identify a cause
and push the fix and saw a reduction of
their ANR rate from 2% to below 0.1% a
95 percent reduction but I think what's
worth calling out here is what we found
afterwards so we did an analysis of
Google Play what was the change of
engagement with the app before and after
the fix and we saw really substant gains
in both daily active users and in
sessions for users across the board now
these are just two examples of
developers who have been able to
leverage the platform to see really
significant gains both at a performance
and a business level now I'm gonna
invite up fergus product manager for
vitals who's going to talk about some of
the ways that we're enhancing the
platform to make it even more powerful
for developers
great job hey Ron I'm very sorry product
manager for Android vitals it's been
incredible to see the improvements that
app developers like yourselves have made
over the past year as a result of using
the tools that we've made available
it's also been incredible to get all the
feedback from you as to how we could
improve Android vials I'm really excited
to show you the new features we have
available today as a result of your
feedback so thank you so much last year
when we announced Android vials as Joel
mentioned we launched three performance
areas battery stability and rendering
today we're announcing two new areas
startup time and permissions battery is
probably the most important performance
area to focus on this is where you
should not unnecessarily use the CPU are
the radios on the device which drains
develop users batteries which means they
can't use your app as long stability is
all about building a robust and reliable
application so the users are using your
application without freezes our crashes
and rendering is all about building a
fast and responsive application that's
silky smooth and doesn't lag our stall
on users which startup time we're
enabling you to be able to provide a
quick launching application to users no
matter what state your app has been in
there's three different metrics we have
here and I'm gonna go through each one
so first we have slow cold start slow
here is defined as five seconds or more
and cold start is when your app has not
been launched in a while and is going
from activity launched to activity
running and the app is not a memory
slow warm start is where it takes two
seconds or more for your app to go from
actively launched to actively running
where your app is in memory final
startup time metric we have is slow hot
start this is where your app goes from
on restart to activity running and it
takes longer than 1.5 seconds this is
where your app and your activity is in
memory
another new performance area we have is
permissions this is where we want to
help you be able to only request
permissions that users think are
required for the core value of your
application to be provided to them and
if they don't think so
then provide them justification why you
think they should actually provide that
information when we ask users what are
the reasons that you deny permissions
for applications what we find is that
the vast majority of them just think
that the app doesn't need those
permissions so really providing a
justification is critical for you to get
users to be able to give you the
permission that you need to be able to
offer the best functionality possible in
your application in the details view for
permissions we provide a breakdown by
permission group so maybe one of your
permissions users think your app does
need and you get a high percentage of
acceptance for that one and then another
one users don't think you need and you
get a high denial rate for that one and
maybe you don't need that permission in
the first place so maybe you should
rethink it or maybe you just need to
explain to users why your app does need
that permission we have many other
breakdowns across the vilas product for
most files we break it down by app
version by device and by Android version
for wakelocks and wake up's we provide
by tag for a and ours we provide by an
or type and an or name we also provide
at the cluster's view for grouping your
A&Rs together so you can be able to see
which ones are similar and be able to
debug those at clusters for clashes we
also provide clusters when I've been
building apps at Google and prior to
Google one of the things I struggled
with the most was being able to
understand how do I compare with other
apps troffers similar functionality
who else is struggle with understanding
if their app is performing well compared
to other apps okay lots of people share
the same struggle as iPad we are now
going to announce calorie level
benchmarks in the Play console this
enables you to be able to see okay for
start time you can see here there's
board games are much faster at starting
than racing games and we also provide
the 25th 50th and 75th percentile
breakdown for each of the categories we
will default to the category that you
list yourself in the store you can
select any other category that you want
to be able to compare yourself with in
case you don't think that your app is as
related to that category on the details
page for every bio we show you this
breakdown for the category benchmark and
then you can be able to also see what
exact percentage you are relative to the
other apps in that category on the
redesigned Android vials overview page
we show you each of the metrics in the
performance area we show you what was
your percentage of users impacted in the
last 30 days what was the percentage of
user impacted in the previous 30 days
and we show you the benchmark comparison
this enables you to be able to quickly
see ok which one of these performance
areas should I actually look into and
which specific metric might require more
attention and so you can see here the
last one in the list you're in the
bottom 12%
that's probably one you want to
investigate the weather channel has been
early access partner for these features
that we're showing today for the past
couple of weeks and one of the pieces of
feedback that they've had is that's been
really great for them to be able to use
calorie level benchmarks to make the
case within their company as to why they
should invest in performance because
they can show how they stack up versus
competing apps I hope you're able to use
similar data to be able to make the case
within your company if you want to learn
more about benchmarks in the Play
console we have a session on tomorrow at
9:30 a.m. although all Android BIOS
should be paid it should be viewed as
ways to be able to enhance the
experience of your application some
vitals are more important to offering
the best user experience possible and so
that's why we're putting this at feature
at the top of the Android vitals
overview page which is core vials these
are the vials they should pay most
attention to these are the ones that
will imp
your remote ability and ranking in the
store along with many other signals but
you should really pay attention to these
signals you'll see the list of the
vitals here we have the initial four so
stock partial wakelocks where you hold a
wakelock for over an hour in the
background excessive wake ups where you
have 10 wake up's happening per hour a
in our race where you have an user
experienced app not responding for 5
seconds or more in a day and a crash
rate where they have one crash in the
day if you're in the bottom 25% for any
of these bad behavior vials then you
will be flagged as having a bad behavior
this is where you will see a tile at the
top of the core violence section to
alert you and when you click on that
tile you'll be able to go into the
details view and see which specific apk
is exhibiting that bad behavior and we
provided information to help you debug
that issue one another major requests
that we've had over the past year is to
get alerted when there is an issue
that's introduced with their vitals and
so we're really happy to announce
anomaly detection so this is where
you'll get flagged with an alert at the
top of your Android vital section are
they in or and crash clusters to let you
know what is the issue that you have and
and you can click on that tile and be
able to go in and see details you can
also be able to sign up to get email
alerts or when one of these anomalies is
detected and when you get one of those
emails you there's a link directly to
the issue so you can be able to
investigate ok when did this issue occur
and for how long did it happen the big
fish games team that have built many
games that have reached over 10 million
installs have found great results we're
using these tools by being an early
access partner for these these features
over the past couple of months and
they've reduced our crash rate by 45
percent for one of their top games I'm
now going to hand over to Wojtek to talk
about how you can debug and improve your
specific core vitals issues
Thank You Fergus hi everyone my name is
Wojtek I work on the developer relations
team and I work closely with the Android
teams at Google to help you developers
build better apps and today I want to
talk about how you can fix some of these
core vitals that fergus mentioned in
your apps in your code and first I want
to start with stability and let's talk a
little bit about ANR's so we keep saying
this acronym right ANR's but what are
they really so ANR's in other words
application not responding events now
this happens whenever in your app some
long-running operation blocks your main
thread now the main thread is
responsible for things like responding
to user events such as taps or redrawing
the UI for every frame so if we block it
if the main thread cannot do that in a
timely manner the app will just seem
frozen and then after a few seconds the
system will notice that and will pop up
this annoying dialogue that lets the
user actually close the app and as
developers we really don't want that to
happen so what are some common causes of
A&Rs like what kind of operations can
block our main thread well probably the
most common ones and our network and
disk operations also called as IO now
networks are congested remote servers
are slow so can be your flash drives or
the file system can be busy with other
operations and so as developers we
should never never do network or disk
operations on the main thread but you
know I just prepared two code examples
to show you that it's not always easy to
do the right thing even though if I'll
probably agree with me we can still make
mistakes so here for example in my
activity on create I decided oh I'm just
gonna prepare this shirt preferences
object to use later I'm just gonna
create it and and not do anything with
it right now and then somewhere else in
my app probably on a background thread I
will actually get some information like
read an integer or a string or whatever
and I thought okay that's good I will I
will not be doing disk operations on a
main thread
what I didn't realize though is that the
implementation of her preferences on
Android
actually eagerly reads data from disk
the moment you create them and so that's
that's actually the line of code that
does disk access so I was wrong it's
it's not always obvious and let me show
you another even trickier example so
here I'm doing some hypothetical network
operations in my app so let's say I want
to check if my intent contains some kind
of URL so I'm comparing the two and then
I say I want to open connection to that
URL I'm gonna save the headers to some
variable for later use and then I
actually open an input stream and
finally finally in the end I am reading
bytes from the network so this is a
pretty complicated a P I to be honest
and how am I as a developer is supposed
to know if that first line open
connection creates the network requests
and actually blocks my thread or is it
the last one where I actually request to
read you know bytes of data to actually
read them into my application or is it
something else and well it's not obvious
actually in this example this line of
code will perform a network operation
like the first time I'm trying to access
headers only then will the connection be
opened and the first bytes will be read
and so as a developer again I failed I
would I didn't know which operation does
the network access but fun fact on an
even older Android version this line
just creating a just checking if two
URLs are equal can perform network
operations ok so why am i showing you
all this because I want to convince you
that just as developers we cannot know
everything and you will use libraries
that you don't you're not familiar with
or other api's and that's why I suggest
you use strict mode for your debug
builds why why you develop your apps our
strict mode is an API that existed on
Android for a long time and it's pretty
easy to set up you just set a thread
policy in your application on create or
in your activity on create and you tell
strict mode I want you to detect all
disk operations in my application on
this thread and I also want you to
detect network operations and then you
tell strict mode what you want to
to be so first of all of course we want
to see it in logs so we can debug it
later but you know logs are easy to miss
like log cut can be noisy sometimes so
for my debug builds I'm also gonna go
and say penalty death which will
actually crash my app whenever I do the
wrong thing and access network or disk
on the main thread not like I said you
don't want to do any of that in your
production release bills because you
don't want your users app to crash okay
so now I go back and run my code that I
just showed you and look at my logs
because my app obviously crashed and I
see the exact cause and I can go and
debug that so I can see there was a
strict mode discrete violation and I can
see in the stack trace the culprit is
yeah it's the gut default preferences
call that I did in my activity on create
sir great this lets me actually go and
fix that ok so we covered network and
disk operations and how to catch them
you know sometimes you don't even need
to hit remote servers or disk to cause a
long-running operation all it takes is
literally just calculating something for
a long time doing a very long loop and
something like that so here in this
example this is a sample sudo cool game
and how it works is when the user opens
the app the Sudoku board is actually
generated in memory it's not read from
this it's not pulled down from a server
somewhere and there's actually a pretty
long complex calculation happening to
show that first board to the user so
they can play it and so it's just one
call generate board and as you can see
on a on a slow device this could cause
an INR because I'm doing that on the
main thread so first of all how am I
supposed to know as a developer that
this call generated can be long well I
really suggest that you use Android
profiler regularly if you ever suspect
there is any performance problem in your
app so here for example I took a CPU
trace of the method generate board in
the Android profiler and I can
immediately see that it's a complex
recursive call that takes a long long
time to finish and so now I know I
should not be running it on the main
thread oh and by the way there's a new
thing in the end or Android profiler
that we just released in the cannery
today now you can debug and profile your
apps
time so that's pretty handy okay so
going back to our problem with our
generate board call what can I do with
it
so strictmode has this has this method
of telling it that a call can be slow so
here as a developer is the person who
created this pseudo algorithm I will
tell strictmode
to note the slow call and now whoever
else touches my code and is using it and
uses strick know as well if they also
set the detect custom slow calls thread
policy again they will get notified
their app from the crash they will get
the log and they will know to never call
that generate board method on the main
thread alright so so what are some other
causes of A&Rs be careful if you're
doing any kind of inter process
communication and expect a result don't
do it synchronously on the main thread
if you're calling some other application
if if that call is leading your process
you basically don't control what happens
on the other side
IPC goes through layers of the operating
system the other process can access
network and disk to service service your
request so just remember to do it on the
background thread the next thing is
multi-threaded programming and that's a
really really difficult topic like we
could talk have a whole other session
about this but if you ever find yourself
touching you know low-level primitives
such as locks and synchronization
eventually there's a high chance you
will create a deadlock in your
application or hit some other problem
that blocks your main thread and these
are very tricky to debug
however Android vitals does give you
some information that will help you
debug these kinds of problems so if you
open any an ANR in the vital in the
vitals console we actually provide you
with the trace files pulled from the
devices that suffered from these ANR's
and so you can look at thread States and
see if they were blocked waiting on any
resource to become available and we even
highlight the problems that we think
might be happening in this trace okay
and the last thing I want to mention is
as a cause of ANR's
is slow broadcast receiver handling now
not
every developer realizes that if you set
a broadcast receiver in your Android
manifest and then it gets cold that the
own receive method actually happens on
the main thread and you you're not
supposed to perform any long-running
operations in it and there's a timeout
about about 10 seconds that the system
will allow this method to run and then
it will kill your process and so you
know sometimes though whenever you
you're using a broadcast receiver maybe
to show a notification to the user maybe
you still need a little piece of data
maybe from the disk like reading some
name or profile picture to show in a
notification so you actually need to do
that disk access so what can you do in
this case now broadcast receivers have
this method called go acing it's
basically a way to tell the broadcast
receiver from the on receive method that
you need to do some longer running
operation and then you spin up your a
separate thread yourself you do the
operation and then remember to call
finish when you're done if you don't do
that
the system will still realize that
you're blocking and might potentially
kill your app and remember don't treat
this as some kind of long-running
service this is not the case for
broadcast receivers and the reasonable
time limit still applies so you should
literally just grab the things you need
and the separate thread and finish as
soon as possible ok let's talk a little
bit about crashes and you know it's
really difficult to give general advice
on how to avoid crashes in a setting
like this because every app will be
different every crash will be different
however I can give you some advice that
I think might be helpful so you know as
four years as an Android developer I've
seen my code or code from other people
start up start very simple and we
release something and then things start
crashing on users devices and so we add
all these safety measures like checking
for Knolls everywhere and checking for
activity life cycles and then if that
fails we just wrap everything in a
try-catch and just hope that this
problem doesn't hit too many users but
that's not as not the greatest solution
right it doesn't actually solve the
underwrite underlying problem and that's
why my first piece of advice to you is
don't try to reinvent the wheel and use
ready to readily available libraries
that solve problems that you as
developers face now some of the most
difficult parts of Android we heard
about it from you from developers is
handling life cycles and that's why last
year we released some of release the
architecture components such as live
data view model for handling that and
also we released room and and paging
components for loading data into your
application into your UI this year at
i/o we're announcing two new components
as part of the Android jetpack
initiative
this is navigation for handling all
kinds of fragmented activity transitions
and navigation problems and the work
manager for scheduling work in the
background but you know you don't have
to use components provided by Google
there are a lot of great third-party
libraries out there and if you think
they're useful to you and your
application and they will solve your
problems feel free to use them as well
ok the second thing I want to mention
when talking about crashes is Kotlin now
also last year at i/o we announced
Kotlin as a first-class supported
language for Android developers and
before I say say anything more let me
just say that I know it's not a silver
bullet it will not solve all your
crashes in your application however
because of the no safety that's built
right into the language it can save you
for some common classes of errors that
you might otherwise hit with if you
build your apps with just Java and some
of the night other nice things about
cuddliness are that it's highly
interoperable with existing Java code so
you don't have to go all in and
transform all your apps into Kotlin you
can start slowly adding it into your
applications and see if it helps you and
actually divert the developers love
Kotlin and we are seeing a steady uptick
in Kotlin usage in android apps and it's
also easy and fun to learn so I really
encourage if you haven't tried it yet
it's fully supported by us and you're
free to use it in your applications and
the last thing about crashes that I want
to talk about is private and hidden
api's now we offer an SDK to developers
that's backed by the
commentation and basically public
methods public interfaces that you can
use but developers are finding ways to
access methods in the android framework
that exists on devices they were never
intended for you to use and that's not
because we you know we don't like you as
developers and we don't want you to give
you nice things it's just because that
these api's are not ready to be used
they're not guaranteed to exist they
might be implementation details on a
certain device we might even remove them
on the next Android version or a device
manufacturer can go and customize
Android to remove them as well the thing
is you should never use private or
hidden api's in your apps but in order
to enforce that and to actually help you
make your apps crash less in case these
api's change we're introducing
restrictions and Android P Developer
Preview that means basically you have to
stop using private and hidden api's in
your apps and we did a similar thing in
Android Duga with the NDK where we said
you can no longer access libraries that
exist on the system partition if they're
not exposed by public indicated api's so
please if you can migrate from private
API is to public api's that are
documented and guaranteed to work to
make her apps safer and let's talk a
little bit about battery and stock
wakelocks
so wakelocks it's an API that lets you
basically keep the device from entering
a deep sleep so from conserving the
d'bari and a stock way clock is when you
use the API and because of a bug or
because you forgot you acquire wakelock
but you never release it so it just
keeps keeps the CPU running and it keeps
draining the battery on your users
devices so what's the best way to avoid
having a stuck way clock in your
application well you can't have one if
you don't use way clocks that's
literally the simplest thing and
actually in modern Android development
there's rarely a situation when you have
to use a way clock if we think about
activities so whenever the user is
actually using your app and for some
reason you want to keep the screen on
instead of setting away clock
programmatically
just use a flag on the window that will
tell the system to keep screen on
there's no way to leak it for services
if you schedule them as jobs instead of
having your custom freerunning services
the job scheduler will hold the wakelock
for you and so again you can don't have
to do that yourselves
similarly with alarm manager if you use
it to schedule an alarm in a broadcast
receiver there will be a wake lock held
for you for the duration of on receive
so if you don't use wake locks you don't
even need that permission in your
manifest and you can't you know you
can't leak them so that's great but if
you must use a wake lock if you find a
situation where you have to use it
remember to always choose a partial wake
lock all the other types of wake locks
are deprecated on newer Android versions
and then always set a timeout value in
wake lock acquire so that in case you
leak it the system will clean that clean
up the wake lock for you after the
timeout expires remember to give it a
static descriptive tag without any
counters or even worse like private
sensitive information that way we can
surface the name of the wake lock in the
Android vitals for you for easier
debugging and then remember to always
call defensively and assume things can
go wrong and you know use things like
try and finally blocks to make sure that
you release the wakelock as soon as
you're done with it and the last thing I
want to talk about today is excessive
wake ups and I think the biggest cause
for excessive wake up's is the use of
this old old API called our alarm
manager and specifically the wakeup type
of alarms now let me give you the 3 R's
of alarm manager remove calls to wakeup
alarms if possible reduce the frequency
if you have to use them for some reason
and if you can replace your alarms with
other API such as firebase cloud
messaging
whenever the wake up has to happen for
something that changed on your server
and you can send it as a push message or
use one of the job scheduling API such
as the newly announced work manager or
even job scheduler or sync manager and
you know with intelligent job scheduling
you get a lot of things for free such as
automatic backup and retry if your job
fails for any reason
you get criteria based scheduling so you
can only wake up the device when it has
network or is charging so that you don't
actually run your code and themselves
unnecessarily you get those and
statement stand by compliance and like I
mentioned before even automatic way
clock handling and there's a whole
session about background processing and
work about work manager API specifically
where you can learn more about this
today so I mentioned the Android
profiler before and I'm happy to say
that today in Android studio we're also
announcing the new energy profiler so
that you can debug any kinds of problems
with wakelocks
if you use them in your app and also see
detailed information about alarms and
jobs scheduled in your application if
you're interested to hear more about the
profiler please go to the session
tomorrow and with that let me invite
Fergus back on stage just to talk to you
about what more you can do to improve
quality over your apps thanks great so
we've covered a lot about what's
available in Android violence in the
Play console I'm just quickly going to
go through some of the other tools that
you can be able to use to be able to
improve the performance of your
application all of Android BIOS is based
on data that is collected from users
devices so these are users that are
actually being affected by the issue
itself we would love for users not to
actually be impacted by in these issues
at all and so we'd encourage you to do
more pre-launch testing of your
application to find these issues before
rolling it out to users there's a
session on this on Thursday at 9:30 and
encourage you to attend that one over
the past couple years we've made radical
improvements to the Android operating
system to help users be able to get more
out of their device in terms of
performance and for the battery to last
longer there's major improvements with
the latest version of Android and that
was covered in the keynote today you can
learn a lot more about that on Thursday
at 11:30 in this session here Wojtek
covered a bunch of different tools
within Android studio to help you with
improving your core vials but there's a
bunch of other profilers and tools
available to improve all the rest of
your vials and so
encourages to use Android studio even if
you're using another ID for example to
build your game
firebase offers many tools to help you
be able to track the performance of your
application at crash' lytx and firebase
performance monitoring being the most
relevant ones for the this talk we
encourage you to use those SDKs if you
want to be able to do custom logging of
your issues that you might be having
with your application note there will be
a difference in the data that's
collected from the firebase SDK versus
what's collected true Android vials
which is from users who have opted in to
sharing the data with Google and our
partners at you if you want to learn
more about firebase performance
monitoring and crashlytics you can
attend this talk at 11:30 tomorrow we
covered a lot in terms of what's
available in Android vials in the Play
console today but there's a lot more to
learn and you can hear all about that on
developer.android.com slash vitals just
to quickly recap we started by covering
why performance is vital overall and
hopefully you all agree that it is
that's why you're here today so thank
you then we covered what's new in vitals
and I hope you take advantage of these
new tools then we talked about how you
can debug these core vitals issues and
finally what's available beyond play
console Android Wales we'd love to hear
your feedback on this talk if you're
gonna be able to go to this URL provide
your feedback we'd love to hear from you
if you have any questions for us you can
meet us from a four o'clock to five
o'clock at this stand it's on the other
side of the lot and we'll also be
available at the Google Play console
sandbox from 2:00 p.m. to 5:00 p.m.
tomorrow to answer any of your questions
thank you all very much for joining us
here today we yeah
we hope that you'll make radical
improvements to your application over
the next year and that you'll get
covered in our i/o talk next year so
best of luck to you all with improving
your application thank you
[Music]